Nicholas is in Florida hey Nicholas how
can we help hi Dave
so my wife and I were almost at the end
of baby steps ooh we only had a little
over a grand left and about three weeks
ago or a car that we got it from a
friend and he was nice enough to let us
stay payments on it the engine blew and
we had to use our emergency fund and
even a little bit of it more to pay him
and we were without work for a week we
try to look for other solutions but we
felt so stuck in them I did a super
thing and I financed a $10,000 car and I
was just going there feeling like it's
just what I had to do which already felt
bad enough and as I was sitting in the
finest manager's office I just remember
one of the calls that you say off and
we're the borrower's displayed to the
lender and I just from that moment until
now I just was so crushed I feel like I
have a big sinus idiot on my head and I
don't know what to do me too man I just
try to turn the lights off on the side
[Laughter]
oh let's see
let me get this straight you did
something stupid does that mean you are
stupid you know no it doesn't because if
you if you didn't realize you did
something stupid and you did something
stupid then you're probably stupid too
me too me too you know
so what do you do ken when you fall off
the wagon
well you dust yourself off and get back
yeah but reflect first I like to add a
little step in there look let's let's
look at why did I fall off what drove me
to that and it was fear you know I I
think we've got to understand we have to
learn from these moments it's not enough
just to say alright I'm not stupid and I
can get back out of it because you can
but I want you to examine why you made
that decision what drove you to making a
nonsensical decision
it's not even stupid you just you
weren't in you weren't in a place of
clarity while you're doing it you knew
it was wrong
yeah so what's happening in your head
that allows you to do that because if
you don't fix that part to Ken's point
you'll do it again right that's that's
that's what we want to reflect on so
what drove you what was your driver I
mean we need a car for our work and we
just felt like there was nothing else we
wanted to get another cheap car like our
one before but we just had this feeling
like we would go into the same thing
where it would also break again and we
just be going into the cycle we were
planning we're planning as of right now
to pay this one off within a year but I
knew that even with that I just felt
like there was something better but just
I'm not gonna pick this apart but I just
want to speak to the fear because you
were afraid it was gonna happen again
it's like being afraid you're gonna get
struck by lightning twice and the odds
of that are very very very very very
slim did you get the first card the one
from your buddy did you have a mechanic
look it over before you agreed to buy it
yes we did we had mechanics we had
friends they're familiar with cars okay
he said that it was okay was still
finding a little 2007 Kia so they could
see some dates but overall the people
who are looking at it said it was all
right but we drive a lot so sure so
here's the deal so a bad thing happened
life happens okay you did a you did what
you needed to do there you weren't
reckless it seems and so something still
happened you know it was bad and
something bad happened and so now what
you did is you compounded a bad
situation by going and getting in ten
thousand dollar loan for a car and there
was another way I'll bet there were two
or three other ways and that's what I
want you to reflect on is that even in
those moments where you feel like
there's no other way there are there's
another way sleep on it get about five
other opinions you just needed some
feedback you needed to pause yeah that's
what the lesson is rent a car buy a
thousand dollar car the thing about
thousand other cars is they're
throwaways mm-hmm disposable ten
thousand dollar cars aren't
and and the so what here's your
challenge and here's what you got to
figure out okay is what is going to take
you long term to where you want to go
and I'm not media I don't mean
transportation wise I mean in terms of
the decision making and principles that
you're using with money what's going to
take you where you want to go when
Sharon and I went broke we determined we
became a thorough believers 30 years ago
that borrowing money was not going to
take us where we wanted to go and so
every time we were painted into a corner
every time we were backed into a corner
of someone pointing a metaphorical gun
at our face and said okay the only way
out of this is borrow the only way out
of this is get a 10,000 hour car every
time we just said we can't borrow money
we changed our belief about what is
going to cause us to win and borrowing
money was no longer on that list and so
we never again because we no longer
believe that we never again have
borrowed money and so the problem is is
that your belief was tested and you
didn't believe that the best way and you
thought instead I'm you know you're your
you know your four-year-old kid that
lives inside of all of us said well
you're always gonna be driving a junk
car no you know you drive a junk car you
drive like no one else so later you can
drive like no one else you know what I
Drive now anything I want you know why
because I drove crap for a long time
with bondo as the primary color yes you
know and so I drove like no one else now
I can drive like no one else and so you
gotta you gotta believe that that's
actually going to occur and then you can
go back into a piece of crap when your
other piece of crap breaks that's right
what it's temporary yes see when you
talk about you and Sharon saying we are
not going to choose debt and so we're in
a corner ever so here's what happens
when you focus on never ever ever ever
again having debt guess what happens you
get certain options are removed no and
other options appear so this is a focus
thing so he and again we're not picking
on you at all we've all crap oh yeah
as a result listen for well
over a year and a half first four years
of our marriage Stacy and Eric I drove a
year and a Ford Taurus it didn't have AC
but it was for 30 years no it was good
here yeah absolutely right I'm old a
year and a half a month well you know it
situation here is this he began to say
well that's an option I don't want to be
an option but it's an option I don't
want to be an option I feel bad about it
but it's an option and then it became
the option it wasn't the option your
emotions take over instead of your
belief you got a focus on what I think
you need to do is you need to sit down
and reevaluate what you really believe
is gonna cause you to win with money yep
is it the stuff we teach if it is then
this has to be a one-time thing and by
the way if that's the case sell the car
get rid of the debt now undo the problem
because every time you get in that thing
you're gonna feel like you screwed up
because you screwed up